so Tim Scott announces he's running for
president uh in the Republican primary I
don't think he has any shot at winning
he's polling 1.8 percent Donald Trump
welcomed it and we know that the reason
Trump welcomes Scott running is Trump
does better in polling the more
candidates there are dividing up the
non-trump votes so Trump's glad for it
the other people that seem to be glad
about it are the Fox and Friends crew
Steve Ducey and Ainsley Earhart and
Brian Kilmeade now Ainsley Earhart is
particularly
excited about this she's from South
Carolina and that may be a factor here
but they seem to just be gushing and I
think part of it is Ainsley Earhart
herself is from South Carolina and so is
Tim Scott and then on the other hand I
think they're desperate for someone
other than trump it really doesn't seem
like the scientist has what it takes so
maybe they're interested in Tim Scott
and they say don't underestimate him by
starting at home yeah he's a really nice
guy I love South Carolina and what's
ironic he's he's positive he's
mild-mannered he's seeking to form a
coalition of traditional conservatives
and Evangelical Christianity and
moderate sounds great Ainsley please
send it down Republicans yeah they're
just screaming hello what's going on
Sarah what he is now a rock star in that
area no bitterness this is how far
Charleston has come he's got 22 million
dollars he's got a Super PAC that's got
13 million dollars anyone who dismisses
Tim Scott it's uh you will regret that
well right I don't know why you'll
regret it but you will he's got 22
million it sounds it sounds like
98.2 percent of Republican voters are
currently dismissing Tim Scott I was in
his uh treasury that according to the
SEC is the most any presidential
candidate has ever had at this point wow
you know I almost I almost feel bad
because I feel like almost Tim Scott's
too good for politics there you go he's
too good of a candidate he's too good of
a guy
uh is this weird or is it just me he's
such a great guy to be a preacher and he
did put out an ad that is now running
and Elon Musk came out and said that is
a great ad there you go that clip from
decoding Fox News which who continues to
do great work on Twitter
um the Elon musk's seal of approval uh
and we know we know everything Elon Musk
touches turns to Gold of course Tesla
stock down about 80 percent and Twitter
in shambles so Tim Scott don't
underestimate him as 98.2 percent of
current Republican primary voters are
doing and uh we will see how Tim Scott
does in the meantime let's talk a little
bit about DeSantis Trump